Samuels big challenges coming literally
shaking
I'm just set here in the car with
several leads we don't know who he is
there's googling but he's a
multi-millionaire entrepreneur King Lear
[ __ ] popped
we just left this family stripped from
always well I am in court brought me a
long lunch to dive in this wild
adventure what are we doing let's get
down to business I've been stood from
everything so I'm starting all over
again from scratch this is like a really
important you use it alias name I think
you made it really hard for subhype
opulent with no car no money we've been
kicked out of the networking event
[Music]
streets please nibble on them for the
week I've not eaten today at all you'll
be in the back but I need to start
building my property portfolio again
from scratch with nothing let's see what
half the town within two weeks I've
never seen anything like this before I'm
documenting everything this is the
financial freedom challenge and right
now I have a challenge for you watching
this to share this video on your social
media and write a description of what
this is and what it's about and I'm
going to be choosing the best
description and I will use that on the
real documentary on Boxing Day I'm also
gonna reward you with a 4,000 pound
program but I will personally be helping
you in your journey to financial freedom
as well so share this video write the
description and I'll see you real soon
[Music]